so we have G of X being equal to X to
the fourth minus X to the fifth and what
we want to do without having to graph G
we want to figure out what X values does
G have a relative maximum and just to
remind us what's going on in a relative
maximum so let me draw a hypothetical
function right over here so a relative
maximum is going to happen so you can
visually inspect this is okay that looks
like a relative maximum it's kind of top
of a mountain or top of a hill these all
look like relative maxima and what's in
common
well the graph the function is going
from increasing to decreasing at each of
those points is going from increasing to
decreasing increasing to decreasing it
either of the points or you could say
that the first derivative is going from
positive to negative so if you look at
this interval right over here G prime is
greater than zero and then over the next
interval when you're decreasing G prime
would be less than zero so what we
really need to think about is when does
when does G prime so let me see relative
we care about relative maximum point and
so that's essentially asking when does G
prime go from positive to negative
from from I would for or from G prime
greater than zero to G prime less than
zero and the values that we could look
at are the points are our critical
points and critical points are where G
prime is either zero or it is undefined
so let's think about it where is G prime
of X equal to zero G prime of X is equal
to zero when let's just take G prime of
X you leverage the power rule right here
for X to the third power for X to the
third minus five X to the fourth minus 5
X to the fourth is equal to zero let's
see we can factor out an X to the
so we have X to the third times four
minus 5x is equal to zero so this is
going to happen when X is equal to zero
that I couldn't let me not skip steps so
this is going to happen when X to the
third is equal to zero or 4 minus 5x is
equal to zero for X to the third
equaling zero well that's only going to
happen when X is equal to zero and four
minus five X equaling zero we'll add 5x
to both sides you get four is equal to
5x divide both sides by 5 you get 4/5 is
equal to X so here these are the two
places where where our derivative is
equal to zero now are there any places
where our derivative is undefined
well our function right over here is is
just a straight-up polynomial our
derivative is another polynomial it is
defined for all real numbers so these
are our two critical our critical points
or we could even say critical values now
let's think about what G prime is doing
on either side of these critical values
and I'll draw a little number line here
to help us visualize this and so so
there we go a little bit of a number
line and let's see we care about zero
and we care about 4/5 so let's say this
is negative 1 this is 0 this is 1 and so
we have one critical point at let me do
this in magenta we have one critical
point here at x equals zero and then we
have another critical point I will do
this at x equals 4/5 so 4/5 is right
around there so that is 4/5 and let's
just think about what G is what G prime
is doing in these intervals and eat and
and these critical points are the only
places where we where G prime might
switch sides switch signs so let's first
think about this let me pick some colors
I haven't used yet so let's think about
the interval from negative infinity to
zero so this is the open interval from
negative infinity to zero and we could
just plug in a value we could let's try
negative 1 negative 1 is pretty
straightforward to evaluate so let's see
if
or you're going to have four times
negative one to the third power so
that's going to be 4 times negative 1
minus 5 times negative 1 to the fourth
power so that's just going to be 1 so
let's see this is going to be negative 4
minus 5 which is negative 9 so right
over here G prime is equal to negative 9
and so we know over this whole interval
since it's to the left of this critical
point we know that G prime of X is less
than 0 and so our function itself is
decreasing over this interval and so we
know we need to go from increasing to
decreasing so you can already say well
we can't go from increasing to
decreasing at this critical point
because we're already decreasing to the
left of it but anyway let's just think
about what's happening in the other
intervals so in the interval between 0
and 4/5 so that interval right over
there so it's between 0 and 4/5 well
let's just sample a number there let's
say the number I don't know 1/2 might be
brilliant forward so we can evaluate G
prime of 1/2 G prime of 1/2 is equal to
4 times 1/2 to the third power 1 after
the third power is 1/8 so it's 4 eighths
or it's just 1/2 minus 5 times 1/2 to
the fourth so that's 5/16 - 5/16 and so
this is equal to 8 16 minus 5 16 which
is equal to 3/16 but the important thing
is it's equal to a positive value so in
this blue interval right over there and
actually let me put 4/5 in a different
color so we see that it's not part of
that interval so in this in this light
blue interval right here between 0 and
4/5 G prime G prime of X is greater than
zero so we know our function is
increasing and so let's see what's
happening to the right of this and the
easiest value to try out would just be
would just be 1 so let's try out
x equals 1 it's in that interval so when
x equals 1 I'll just write G prime of 1
is equal to 4 minus 5 4 minus 5 which is
equal to negative 1 so G prime of X is
less than 0 G prime of X is less than 0
so our function so we could say G is
increasing here it is decreasing oh
sorry let me be careful G is decreasing
here the function itself is decreasing
because our derivative is negative then
our function is increasing here because
our derivative is positive and then our
function is decreasing here so at what
critical point are we going from from
increasing to decreasing what we're
doing that at x equals 4/5 so we have a
relative maximum at at x equals 4/5 4/5
if they said well where do we have a
relative minimum point well that's going
to be happen at x equals 0 we're going
from decreasing to increasing
but we've answered their question of
where do we find a relative maximum
point